we had a Dominican Canelo fight come on  [Laughter]  [Music]  Miguel Flores featherweight contender  today we'll be working with mr. Iman on  his boxing we're gonna try to perfect  the perfect Canelo style the number 1 is  the most important part Daniel Jacobs is  a tall opponent you know you can hello  you gotta control him on the outside  Canelo's real good at rolling punches so  a row punches he'll come back and he  [Music]  like I sweat all the my going crazy  my dough don't work man get you some  rest at the cryotherapy whoa I just  finished the true Canelo workout make  sure y'all go watch the fight make for  Canelo birthday coups see somebody get  knocked out download the design atlas  I'm an about to go freeze in the crotch  and see a little bit little recovery you  know throwing that left in the body  [Music]  [Music]  so guys just goodness my kid on recovery  so now I'll take me a shower and attack  my day  [Music]  you